by late 2020 a Woman by the name of
Victoria gray had gone from a year free
from many of her symptoms associated
with the debilitating case of sickle
cell anemia
this made worldwide news because after
all sickle cell has been an incurable
genetic disorder
the disease is caused by misshaped blood
cells due to a mutation in the protein
hemoglobin
instead of being round these sickle
crescent-shaped blood cells get jammed
in blood vessels causing agonizing pain
they also do a worse job at transporting
oxygen throughout the body
based on our own statements Victoria was
concerned that she wouldn't be around
for her kids graduations weddings and
grandchildren
well that is until a clinical trial came
about that offered hope
cells were taken from her body
genetically edited using a technology
called crispr to fix what was wrong and
redeposited
she was a first but surely not the last
to have their lives utterly transformed
by this Gene editing technology
Gene editing it is as powerful as it
sounds
scientists are now able to change the
code of life with relative e using
insert these changes into living
organisms
Gene editing is not a new practice
in fact many of the foods we eat
certainly those found in packaged foods
such as chips and box cereals have
already been altered by Gene editing
however there is a new technique known
as crispr that has turned the field on
its head empowering scientists to
perform the task much more generally
across species and cell types
what is significant about crispr is the
increased speed and efficiency of Gene
editing and the variety and number of
investigators that are now able to
perform such research across many fields
crispr has the potential to dramatically
change how we treat disease what we eat
and maybe even how we age
as a synthetic biology tool
crispr has already been used in cancer
immunotherapies that transform cells
into cancer seeking Destroyers
it's being investigated to correct
genetic disorders
it's being investigated to make our
Foods more robust to Drought pests and
disease
it's being aimed at pests like
mosquitoes to reduce their numbers and
thus disease transmission
is even being explored to bring species
such as the woolly mammoth back from
Extinction
all of these advances are thanks to
effective and efficient mechanisms for
cutting genes to remove unwanted traits
or insert new traits
to gauge how far we have come I
sometimes examine past predictions of
scientists and writers including that of
the late Dr Isaac Asimov
Dr Asimov wrote hundreds of non-fiction
and fiction books
yes hundreds
movies and TV programs such as iRobot
and Foundation continue to be made of
his work even decades after his death
and some of his original Works were a
significant influence for Star Wars
he appeared on the David Letterman show
in 1980 and made predictions about
genetic testing at Birth
synthetic insulin our ability to conduct
gene therapy and potential cancer cures
many of his predictions seem like
science fiction back in 1980
but they have come to pass
children indeed do get tested for
genetic disease
we really do fiddle around with genes to
address specific diseases such as cancer
and we can indeed change the code in
cells to address the body's production
of insulin
it is this technology called crispr
first proposed in 2012 and awarded a
Nobel Prize in 2020 that has
revolutionized and revitalized research
aiming to redesign organisms from many
human purposes
crispr has provided the power
adaptability affordability and access
lacking in earlier techniques
for example crispr is spurring
exploration into de-extinction this is
where scientists are exploring methods
to re-establish long extinct species or
at least chimeras where genomes of
extinct species are married with still
living species
in Greek mythology chimeras are monsters
of mixed origin such as a lion mixed
with a goat
in Modern Biology the term Chimera is
used to describe an organism that is a
patchwork of different species
this chimeric or Patchwork method is
being explored for the extinction of
both the woolly mammoth and the
passenger pigeon among other species
but crispr has far more practical
applications as well
for one it is particularly well suited
to confront genetic disease
by replacing incorrect letters in the
genetic code with proper letters crispr
seems the best chance we have to address
some of those disorders to date
for example in Tay sex disease babies
are born with just one improper base
pair Arrangement among billions of
letters of the genetic code
the Gene and the corresponding protein
enzyme responsible for tasex doesn't
properly break down fats in the baby's
brain as it develops
as a result the brain suffocates as
these fat products accumulate in the
brain tissue
child often dies before reaching
adolescence
several studies involving crispr show
promising results in addressing this
disorder through changing the gene
mutation to a normal Gene
although much work still needs to be
done to ensure safety and efficacy
some argue given the devastation of
these diseases
it is our moral obligation to push for
cures
if we have the power to do so
crispr is also being explored in a host
of cancer immunotherapies
promising results have been achieved for
some cancers where patient's own immune
cells are programmed to attack cancerous
cells
researchers created a therapy that takes
T cells from a patient and Alters them
with an artificial t cell receptor
engineered to Target and Destroy cancer
cells
this approach is called chimeric antigen
receptor T cell therapy or car T therapy
for short
this is one of the most promising
outcomes of synthetic biology again
fueled by crispr
here white blood cells removed from a
patient are reprogrammed to recognize
antigens on cancerous cells
the patient cells are then reproduced
tested and reintroduced into the patient
when the engineered cells come in
contact with the cancerous cells an
immune response is triggered in the
newly engineered white blood cells
attack the cancer
results have also been shown to be
persistent in patients providing longer
term protection
crispr is the first technology with a
demonstrated potential to alter genes of
many species with relative precision
moreover it is also relatively cheap and
easy to use
the genes of many organisms across the
world have been successfully altered by
crispr already
now before you yourself take up stab at
genome engineering when I say cheap and
easy I mean for Specialists with years
of experience working in a lab outfitted
with thousands of dollars worth of
equipment
however the fundamentals of this
technology are not Beyond The General
Public
indeed some advocate for much wider
inclusion of novices in synthetic
biology research
in fact there is a culture surrounding
synthetic biology that is more akin to
early Silicon Valley than to traditional
molecular biology research
crispr-based techniques have inspired a
culture of tinkering and exploring with
genomes
there are all types of maker spaces
around the world where experienced and
not so experienced researchers
participate in synthetic biology to
fiddle with life
to build and design a crispr experiment
scientists often work with companies
that mail them unique crispr tool kits
to help them design and build new
biomolecules that have the power to
alter organisms scientists can simply go
online go to a repository such as ad
Gene design their experiment in order
now before you get any bright ideas
about altering humans yes you after all
I never suggested we should Cure Disease
by creating semi-synthetic humans I
simply presented a problem such as
recessive genetic disorders and
introduced a powerful technology crispr
but in all seriousness you can see how
organically science can evolve when huge
historical challenges meet a sudden
technology offering to address them
the urge is to Simply jump into the work
sometimes without giving as much
thoughtfulness to negative consequences
as we should
in fact co-discoverer of crispr Dr
Jennifer doudna called for a moratorium
on crispr editing of cells that confer
heredity
such as sperm and eggs
she did so in 2015. three years after
her initial discoveries
other Pioneers in the development of
crispr including doudna's collaborator
and co-recipient of the 2020 Nobel Prize
for their work Dr Emmanuel chapontier
signed a similar call for a moratorium
on so-called germline editing in 2019
indeed the power of crispr is a
Minefield of bioethics concerns
from threats of human experimentation
that could lead to human suffering to
developments of bioweapons and superbugs
but before we get into the ethics and
social implications of crispr even
before we discuss How likely any of
these outcomes are let's focus on the
basic biology of crispr and how it works
after which you might be able to
contemplate for yourself how
biologically sound some of the
aforementioned ideas are
now the bioengineering of organisms is
not new
it started with our ancestors thousands
of years ago selecting for edible plants
for favorable characteristics generation
after generation
for example we owe much of our modern
diet to natives of North and South
America
by selecting crops such as corn lima
beans peanuts Peppers potatoes squash
sunflowers and sweet potatoes our human
ancestors were effectively engineering
the foods we eat throughout hundreds and
often thousands of years of artificial
selection
in fact new research suggests that
Mighty Amazon rainforests often thought
of as an untouched unspoiled landscape
was profoundly Changed by thousands of
years of indigenous agriculture
our human ancestors selecting edible and
useful plants year after year to plant
and grow
does the Amazon owe its productivity and
at least in part to humans
perhaps
in terms of understanding heredity it
took all of human history 200
000 years or so until 1866 Gregor Mendel
proposed the concept of genes which he
called factors
based on his experiments with Garden
peas
it took another 87 years until
1953 to discover the three-dimensional
structure of DNA
it took a period of 13 years from 1990
to 2003 to decode the human genome which
involved identifying and mapping all of
the genes in humans a feat involving
many scientists with an approximate cost
of three billion dollars
by 2016 the cost of sequencing had
fallen for millions in 2003 for the
Human Genome Project to only one
thousand dollars a rate of technological
change even faster than Moore's law for
transistors on a ship
by 2019 at least one company was
offering to sequence a human genome for
approximately one hundred dollars
and by the time you experience this
lesson the price will likely be lower
there are methods of genome engineering
other than crispr that are still used
today particularly where effective
research constructs have already been
built around them
but they pale in comparison to crispr's
flexibility in terms of the number of
different types of experiments that can
be performed as well as the reductions
in time and costs
crispr isn't perfect there are still
Kinks to work out for example sometimes
cleavages not specific to the site
intended but newer and more accurate and
more versatile versions of the
technology continue to be developed
so what is crispr in biological terms
let's delve deeper into the specific
mechanisms
crispr is an acronym which stands for
clustered regularly interspaced short
palindromic repeats its name describes a
particular type of repeats in the
system's molecular components
scientists found that in some bacterial
cells there were clusters of repeated
sequences of DNA
the repeated sequences were palindromic
meaning the letters of the genetic code
Within These segments were at the same
on in both directions on complementary
strands
the word mom is a palindrome for example
these clusters of repeated palindromic
sequences were interrupted by sequences
of unknown DNA
so here you had repeated palindromes
Inner Space with novel DNA
also these repeats are bordered by
crispr Associated genes known for short
as cast genes these cast genes code for
two things
proteins called nucleases that cut DNA
as well as proteins called helicases
that unwind DNA
scientists eventually recognize that
some spaces of DNA in the bacteria
correspond to viral DNA
then science has figured out that these
copies of viral DNA amounted to a
bacterial immune system
the palindromes tend to direct the
formation of helical structures that in
this case work to keep the various parts
of the crispr apparatus intact
as it turns out bacterial cells were
using the crispr system to do two things
first copy new segments of the viral DNA
into the crispr system as spaces
second transcribe the stored segments of
DNA into the crispr system in order to
recognize viral strains that had
reinfected the bacterial cell
when an old sequence of viral DNA is
recognized
the bacteria could deploy the crispr RNA
and its nucleases to identify and cut
the viral DNA injected into the cell
thereby inactivating the virus
scientists were not just observing of
bacterial immune system but an immune
system that had adaptive immunity more
sophisticated than scientists had known
existed for bacterial cells
adaptive immunity involves the detection
identification and memorization of
foreign Invaders or pathogens
in case of a second infection from the
same pathogen if a system recognizes the
foreign agent up front they can mount a
more effective and aggressive secondary
attack
in fact vaccines operate based on this
premise
scientists produce vaccines to trigger
an immune response in you so that if you
were to come in contact with a pathogen
you have been vaccinated against you can
mount a more effective secondary
response
the magic is in your immune system
when viruses invade a cell it is a very
intimate infection certain viruses
actually inject their own DNA into the
cell
normally reprogramming the host to
produce more viruses the whole cell May
then explode with new viral particles
however viruses that invade bacterial
cells that are crispr enabled have a
very different experience their DNA can
be cut into short segments that
inactivate the virus
and the segments of the viral DNA are
then added to the crispr apparatus
like a vaccine with the pieces of virus
interspace among the palindromic repeats
to understand why crispr is so powerful
it's important to keep in mind how
numerous viruses are
it's estimated that for every bacterial
cell on Earth there are 10 viruses
this is one reason viruses exert a
tremendous force not only on the Ecology
of infectious disease but also on the
exchange of genetic information across
the spectrum of life
the crispr system engages in this
exchange of genetic material by cutting
strands of viral DNA before an infection
takes hold
again scientists realize this system had
all the parts necessary to potentially
edit whichever genome sequence
scientists chose
overall crispr technology is based on at
least three main features
crispr Associated genes like cas9 to
code for proteins that cut DNA
guide RNA that is programmable targeting
particular Gene sequences
in DNA molecules added to the system to
implant a desired gene into the host
cell
now the cas9 system normally cuts the
DNA of foreign viruses but scientists
hijacked this system to target cells of
their own choosing
cas9 is the first protein associated
with the crispr cast system that could
be domesticated
so to speak to do the cutting of DNA on
our behalf
scientists created a technology out of
the understanding of basic biology of
the crispr system in order to cut
whatever DNA segments we want
building on earlier work what 2020 Nobel
Prize winners doubtna and charpontier
realized was that the crispr system
found in nature can be re-engineered to
Target sequences we choose
what they did was add genetic sequences
they manufactured called guide RNA to
the crispr complex
this Innovation is what makes crispr
compatible with practically any species
that scientists want to Target
here's how guide RNA works say
scientists want to inactivate Gene a in
a mouse
they would simply select a sequence of
approximately 20 base pairs that
correspond to GNA which would tell the
crispr system to make a cut at that
precise location using one of the cast
endonucleases to make breaks in the
Target sequence
now when the DNA is cut causing a
double-stranded break the cell is
triggered to respond employing one of
two Pathways for DNA repair
remember when a cut is made the DNA
molecule will need to be repaired to be
made whole
one pathway is called non-homologous
in-joining the process tends to be error
prone and often simply deactivates the
gene altogether
extra bases can be added but that's
because this is just a sloppy mechanism
of repair as the ends of the DNA are
ligated or glued back together without a
homologous template which would have
prevented deletions and mutations
however using the crispr system
scientists can add template DNA to guide
the rebuilding of the DNA that's how
they push it to the other repair pathway
which is more precise this is called
homology directed repair
this approach incorporates longer
strands of DNA matching sequences
adjacent to the cleavage site which
crispr will introduce
this sets up less error-prone repair
mechanisms of homology directed pathway
which allows scientists to add genes or
genetic sequences in a very efficient
manner
notice the power and importance of basic
scientific research in all of this
crispr started as a foray into the world
of basic science before it became
applied in technology
the terms technology and science are
often conflated but they are really
quite different
science is inquiry and ask questions
often for the question's sake while
technology applies basic science for a
human benefit
crispr started as an attempt by
scientists to better understand how
bacterial cells function and then
understand how bacteria respond to viral
pathogens
this seemingly remote exploration of an
E coli immune system created the
knowledge that led to the creation of
revolutionary technology that may change
what we eat how we deal with often
deadly and debilitating disease and
perhaps even how we age
ongoing Research into basic biological
questions is indispensable because
humans are just not capable of
predicting what topic will lead to the
next technological breakthrough even for
Fields as applied as synthetic biology
and yet cable news programs and other
outlets sometimes make fun of basic
biology
and I admit some of the projects and
topics sound hilarious for example
questions are sometimes raised about you
know why federal agencies use millions
of dollars to study fruit flies
well for one fruit flies can produce in
a new generation every two weeks
and if you want to see the inherited
effects of genetic change
having a new generation every two weeks
lets you study dozens of generations of
fruit flies in just one year
moreover because fruit flies are so easy
to study much of what we know about
modern genetics have been derived from
the use of fruit flies as model
organisms to study fundamental processes
of genetics and cell theory
one of the things I hope to get across
in this course is a sense of humility
unfortunately scientists aren't smart
enough to know exactly in advance what
to study and how to solve some of
Humanity's most pressing problems
and I don't want you to think that
biologists are now able to conjure up
any organism with any traits they wish
genetic engineering is still very much a
maze of new information and Technologies
we aren't yet able to predict all the
results of our changes
there are complex secondary interactions
among genes and proteins
if science has changed just one gene it
often impacts many others
for example researchers have been
frustrated with the result of using
crispr on embryos
they were attempting to Target
individual genes for blindness for
example yet what happened instead was
entire chromosomes were deleted
embryos are a special case because of
their complexity and developmental
nature but also a stock reminder of our
current limitations
understanding the inner impacts and
interactions of genes is a bottleneck in
genetics research we'll consider later
in the course when we talk about
bioinformatics and artificial
intelligence and how they help us
evaluate these complex interactions also
there is no lack of Justified concern
about the potential darker side of
crispr
in theory crispr could be used to build
superhumans and redefine what it means
to be human
although this seems far-fetched there
are many ethical implications of
exploring synthetic alterations to
humans that don't directly address
disease or suffering
when if ever might the risk of this type
of research be justified
also what are the ethical implications
of not using such a powerful technology
to save lives
again Society will have to answer each
of these questions and consistently
grapple with the new Power scientists
have to fundamentally alter The
evolutionary trajectory of species
including our own
rarely do you find new technology that
has the potential to transform Fields as
disparate as medicine including vaccines
and Cancer Treatments to the
environmental Sciences including
conservation biology agriculture pests
and invasive species management and
energy
it is a technology that inspires both
hope and fears based on its ability to
alter life
also changes we make to germ cells also
known as sperm and eggs may be on a
permanent basis
germ cells hold a key to the
evolutionary path of species
by altering germ cells of species using
crispr
scientists now have the ability to alter
future Generations in a single
experiment
think about that
evolution is an iterative process in
which species are influenced just one
organism at a time
they are selected on the basis of
environmental factors and processes
often slowly sometimes over millions of
years before those random changes affect
an entire species allowing them to be
more suited to their environment
now we are looking at making such
changes in an instant we can now implant
genes and germ cells that could continue
to be passed on to Future Offspring in
perpetuity now that's powerful stuff
crispr is a technology that will appear
throughout this course
it will appear when we discuss the
construction of molecular machines that
produce Industrial Products
crispr will appear when we discuss
Cancer Treatments via immunotherapy
it will appear when we cover vaccine
development and viruses when we discuss
Gene drives and solutions to
environmental problems crispr will come
up when we review bioinformatics and
computation agriculture applications in
space regenerative medicine and threats
from synthetic biology
Gene editing is an Ever evolving tool in
the synthetic biology Arsenal
although in perfect the pace of progress
is breathtaking with new advancements
occurring on a regular basis
next time we will begin to discuss
another fascinating application of our
new synthetic biology tools DNA
computing the development of DNA
Computing is a direct result of our
ability to read write and edit DNA at a
high level see you there